Alright, so what does this have to
do with function approximation or regression. So
how does this notion of regression of falling back toward the mean have to do
with this idea of approximating functions, mapping
inputs to outputs, it seems kind of odd.
So it turns out that the relationship
is, here's the, here's the connection between them.
I'm going to draw a graph and on this axis
will be the parent height. And on this axis
will be the average child height. So if we
plot these against each other, let's let me put
the mean up here. Let's say that this is
mean height for the population. And now say that
you know pair, we sort of imagine that parents
of average height will have children of average height.
But parents that are really tall, like that
hypothetical person from before, will have children that
are taller than average but not as tall
as themselves. And similarly people that are very
let's say of smaller stature will have children
that are also you know short. And, but
not quite as short again closer to the
mean. And it turns out that you have this,
this very nice linear relationship between these quantities, and, there's an
important aspect to this. Which is that the slope of this
line is less than one, it's two thirds. Right. If the
slope of this line was one, what would that mean Charles?
>> That would mean that everybody's children had
the, would, the same height of their parents.
>> Right, right, and so that's exactly right, and so
but if this slope is less than one, like it is,
it turns out to be in, in real populations. Then what's happening is the
children are little shorter than the parents.
Children of taller parents are shorter than they
are. And the children of short parents are taller than they are. And that's the
fact that this is less than one is what makes it regression to the mean.
Now this, this was worked out in I believe in
the late 1800s and it was just such a beautiful
way of connecting all these different quantities together. To kind of
think of them as being related in this functional way.
That people said, oh this is really great. I'm going to
use this idea of regression. And what they started to
mean actually was this not this idea of regression to
the mean. But this idea of finding a, a mathematical
relationship based on a bunch of measurements of points. So this term ended up
getting misused. But that's the term that we have now. So regression now refers
to not this idea of collapsing back towards, towards the mean, but, the idea of
using functional form to approximate a bunch of data points. Isn't that weird.
>> That's pretty cool.
>> There's another example of this sort of idea where where a reasonable
word, like, like regression which we're referring to some physical thing
in the, in the world due to experiments like psych experiments at
this point became this mathematical concept where the name doesn't really
fit anymore, like there isn't really anything regressing in what we're doing.
>> Mm-hm.
>> There's another, really important example
that we're going to get to the later
in the course. Do you, do you know what I'm thinking of Charles?
>> No.
>> So reinforcement learning is my field
of study. And often your field of study.
>> Often.
And it turns out that reinforcement learning doesn't mean what
the words mean anymore. That this was a concept that
the psychologist used to explain what they were observing. And
then some mathematicians, well let's call them computer scientists, took
the word themselves, started to use it and used it
wrong, but now it stuck. [LAUGH] And regression is another
example like that. They, the word is sort of being
used wrong, but it stuck and that's what we're going to use.
>> This explains why every time I have a conversation
with a psychologist about reinforcement learning, we talk past each other.
>> Yes, they get very confused. I tried it to tell them upfront that's not
really what I mean, but I'm going to use
the words anyway, but it still confuses them.
>> Hmm.